for more than 850 years Nostradamus
dominated the heart of Paris in a matter
of hours it became an inferno ravaged
shell but crucially still standing
even with its timber roof inspire gone
eaten up by the flames
the huge Gothic cathedral that took a
century to build remains an
architectural religious national and
international landmark Westminster Abbey
was built in its Gothic style on the
orders of King Henry the third following
a visit to Paris in the 1200 the legacy
of knotted arm stretches far beyond
France this is a an absolute disaster
this building was one of the great early
works of Gothic architecture it came in
a city that was developing Gothic
architecture at the end of the 12th
century it refined the style not trodden
as one of the great exponents of it and
it went on to influence all subsequent
cathedrals here Sinatra dom is a
stepping stone for our own Westminster
Abbey so it's an incredibly important
building for all of us Henry the sixth
with king of both England and France his
French coronation took place at not
'adam Napoleon was made Emperor at the
great Cathedral and Joan of Arc
beatified there inside the thick stone
walls irreplaceable fixtures and
artifacts the great organ which dates
back to medieval times survived the fire
as did the three rows stained-glass
windows unmatched anywhere else the
altar before which so many have prayed
also remains saved too from the flames
the crown of thorns said to have been
worn by Christ at the crucifixion and a
nail from his cross historical novelist
Ken Follett who was due to make a
documentary about knotted arm says the
cathedral treasures are priceless you
can rebuild the church but you couldn't
replace the crown of thorns there was
only one of those and if that had been
lost there would never be another one so
you're absolutely right the uniqueness
of some of these cathedral relics makes
them
absolutely priceless but it turns out
that a great many have been saved a
service was underway when the fire
started
but it'll be many months maybe years and
has a cost of hundreds of millions of
euros before the great Cathedral is
restored to its ancient glory and its
congregation and treasures can return
but restored it will be and not a Dharma
once again with a pride of palace